santiago el cabrero de san martín de
tábara lleva años denunciando el
abandono institucional de las
poblaciones rurales y el olvido de su
importancia para el cuidado del monte el
fuego parece darle la razón en cuestión
de minutos y él llevó todo por delante
un querido compañero pastor de ovejas
quedó abrazado por el yang una de las
cuadrillas forestales que murió el
hombre 64 mil hectáreas arrasadas en dos
incendios en zamora en el noroeste de
españa en las últimas semanas en el
primero ardieron 30.000 hectáreas de la
sierra de la culebra una de las mayores
reservas de lobos de europa aún se
lloraban las pérdidas cuando un nuevo
fuego devoró otras 30.000 hectáreas en
la misma zona en san martín de tábara
están las cabras de santiago y de sus
hijos muchos han quedado ciegas otras
están teniendo abortos la producción ha
bajado más del 50% la población local
culpa del desastre al abandono de las
zonas rurales que favorecen la
despoblación y ya una legislación en su
contra a los pocos guardias que hemos
quedado aquí nos han ignorado zamora es
parte de la denominada españa vaciada la
que dejan los jóvenes a no encontrar
oportunidades ni apoyos los hijos de
santiago se quedaron
con el beato de tábara una que sería
ecológica durante cinco años por
normativa no podemos postular en los
pastos que ya se han quemado el futuro
es incierto a la que sería se acerca en
las autoridades para escuchar las
demandas de la población la principal es
que se declara el área zona catastrófica
concepto uno es de indemnización se
constituir de recuperación la obra
también decidió formar una familia en lo
que llama una simbiosis con el
ecosistema rural sus abejas y su futuro
se calcinaron en el incendio tanto a
ovejas y cabras y demás al final hacen
una limpieza en el ecosistema tremenda
de sus diez asentamientos de abejas el
fuego ha pasado por nueve todo lo que
hay en el suelo es la es la miel que nos
cosecha nosotros las tenemos que sacar
de aquí y donde las llevas si 30
kilómetros a la redonda está todo
quemado la miel del aura obtuvo un oro y
un platino en un concurso internacional
antes de esta catástrofe y no piensa
renunciar a lo que ha elegido como forma
de vida como santiago y sus hijos
la supervivencia del campo pasa por el
apoyo a la vida rural y su propia
supervivencia